[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
imaging long-range neuronal connections
in the mouse brain by light sheet
fluorescence expansion microscopy
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltenny biotech
to learn more visit miltennybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
dr martin k schwartz group leader
functional neuro connectomics group
institute of experimental epileptology
and cognition research ieee cr
university of bonn
professor ulrich kubicek professor for
biophysical chemistry university of bonn
and mr juan eduardo rodriguez phd
candidate institute of physical and
theoretical chemistry university of bonn
dr schwartz professor kuvichek mr
rodriguez you may now begin your
presentation
[Music]
yeah thank you very much for this kind
introduction
and uh yeah it's my pleasure to start
today's uh
educational lecture
so you you realize with three speakers
let me just give you some background why
we have three speakers as also how is
the how we arrange the talk so i will in
the first few minutes the first
few slides talk a bit about the
motivation the biological question
behind why we are interested in imaging
long-range neuronal connections
and then uh kubichek will continue with
the
with the the basics of uh
the the technique the basics about the
light sheet and lighting expansion
microscopy and in the end it will get
really interesting when they do we then
talk about we'll show you results and
we'll talk about the achievements that
we did so far using these techniques
now let me
let me see
next
it worked so what is our motivation so
we are interested so my group is
actually interested in a very
very uh
form of learning that is that this
habituation is a very simple form of
learning and specifically to orders i
will come to this in a second but what
is also motivating us is a
quote from a nobel laureate
sydney brenner who won the nobel prize
in physiology of medicine 2002 for
c elegans for ptosis but what he said i
found really inspiring and we found the
group this
is presenting to you they found really
inspiring it says that progress in
science depends on new techniques new
discoveries new ideas and probably in
that order so he puts the progress
the the development of new techniques
the techniques at the forefront and we
would like to to keep up with this
spirit and this spirit actually
motivated
our our
the research and the in the topic that
we're presenting today so what is the
topic in specific we are trying to
understand the connectomic organization
of the wiring diagram between hdb that
is the horizontal diagonal band
and the ob that is the ob the ideal
factory bulb that controls the simple
form of learning that controls
habituation
now
right
let me see
next
okay
so our interest is habituation as i said
before and specifically to orders but
let me just give you a general idea what
habituation is for those who are not
that much in the in the in the field so
habituation is kind of a
type of non-associative learning
where a non-reinforced response to a
stimulus decreases after repeated
presentation of that stimulus so what
does this mean let me just give you a
short
short
example
so probably most of you i have kids and
if if if i present my kids at home a new
toy
so as a function of time
the more often i present this the the
toy to this kid the the toy to the kid
it gets less interested so it spends
less time with this toy because he knows
it already so it means that the the the
kid habituates in the weight of this toy
right so what is this good for what is
the consequence of this habitation what
does the the the community believe why
this is important we think that it's
generally assumed that lowering a
response to a stimulus that has no
consequences
frees up cognitive researches to
stimulate that might be more important
biologically more important
now how do we study the habituation in
mice and how do we study the habituation
to odors so what we in principle do is
we put the mouse into an open filter
arena and in the middle we place
you see this on the right hand side we
place a
petri dish with an odor and then we
present this mouse
to the to the three times to the same
to the same odor right and what you can
see here then on the under
on the plot on the very right side right
on the right hand side is that
the latency
increases
as a function of the number of
presentations meaning that the mouse
the latency is the time the mouse takes
from to run from the corner to the order
and this increases meaning that the the
the more often you present the mouse to
the same order
as a function of time the mouse gets
less interested so it habituates to them
to this to this order and the
to show that this is really habituation
and just not fatigue we present in the
in the fourth run and novel order and
you see in the novel order the mouse
runs very fast again in the in the
middle of the arena because she she uh
the mouse gets again interested
yeah
so uh
let me see you in the next slide let me
show you in the next slide how we
how we
try to figure out the circuit the
circuitry that controls this this type
of learning this habituation
and
just to remind you the olfactory bulb
represents the first processing center
uh in olfaction so incoming infection
incoming odors are first processed
affect your body but so we thought it's
very likely that the neurons that
connect to their factory pipe the
neurons that influence that the activity
of the factory but might be involved
into habituation process that i showed
you before
yeah
and we checked this by
by uh by by retrograde monotron synaptic
tracing using uh the rabies viruses so
what you in principle do is you inject
this virus in the olfactory blood
and what you see then is all the neurons
that project to these reaches are
regulating this region and on the right
hand side you see already a picture that
has been
recorded with light sheet microscopy
that is what's called ultra microscopy
with
conventional tissue clearing techniques
and what you see here that there's very
very prominent projections from a region
called hdb horizontal diagonal band in
human it would be the horizontal
diagonal band of broker that that that
connects to the factory part so indeed
we identify we and others identified
these type of neurons that
regulate activity in the in the in in
the bulb
and in order to show that these neurons
are also
uh uh
bringing about this phenotype so the
ability of these neurons what we did is
we
this is usually what you do you can
silence these neurons you can delete
this region you can silence these
neurons by
several different techniques we use
tetanus toxin nitrogen but in principle
you take out that you you inhibit the
activity of these neurons that project
to the olfactory bible what you see here
on the right hand side in in dairy blue
is that
habituate as the older habituation is
completely abolished that means that
this mouse cannot
does the does not habituate the order it
is like like an outside my patients
right if you look into the mirror and
whenever you look in the mirror you see
a new face so the mouse
cannot uh
does not have it to it but showing
indeed that this region is constantly
linked as controlling odour habituation
in the mouth
now as a next step what we did is
we did the physiological analysis of the
projection of these neurons of the
projection
of these neurons into the refactory
bible we did this by two photon
calcium imaging of projections
uh from the ob from the from the hdb
within the olfactory bulb and what we
can just to make a long story short what
we what we can show here is that indeed
these
neurons in the hdb are activated by
orders so they show response to orders
and moreover they don't
they not only show response to orders
but they are even show
specific responses to order
and this uh
leaves us brings me already to the end
of my presentation and leaves us with
the question
so we i i could show you that the hdb
projections i ordered you that could
show you that loss of we could show that
loss of hdb function abolishes a factor
habituation and we know that the hdb is
synaptically somehow connected to the ob
and now
what what is what is still missing is
they sort of like the hardware that
controls that allow that that controls
this this circuitry and uh so we are
teamed up with the team of uh
uh to make a connectomic a
reconstruction
of this region to see exactly who is
connecting with whom with the
ultimate aim to generate computational
models realistic models to better
understand
their biology and you see here this is a
formidable problem
with very very high uh
resolution but this will be explained by
by only in the next
10 minutes thank you very much
yeah
so what are the tasks and challenges
that we face when we want to do such
studies
as martin mentioned the the most
important point is that we need to
image extended three-dimensional regions
in the mouse brain
and secondly we don't want only to
image extended regions but at a very
high resolution at synaptic resolution
in order to make out the details of the
connections
and the problem
is i show you here at the lower left
graph an
image of the section of such a mouse
brain
the problem is that it's opaque
and that it's very large for microscopy
and so we have here a special
technique that we need to use and
as a title already indicated of our talk
this is light sheet
microscopy
so in order to remind you
what the speciality of large microscopy
is i made these two sketches here
you see in normal microscopy the
illumination occurs via the objective
lens on the left shown on the left hand
side
and the problem is that the complete
extended sample is then illuminated and
we produce a lot of fluorescence
background
that can be overcome when we take the
trick or when we use the trick of
illuminating illuminating the sample
from the side
as is done in logic scanning microscopy
and we see that then
we illuminate only that region that is
finally being imaged so we
illuminate only the focal region
the idea of this technique is pretty old
it was invented by the monday and
zedentov already in 1903
it was revived in the 90s of the last
century
and then really
put to an
a new use by the work group of ancestor
together with januszkin in 2004
and since then the number of
publications using this technique is
really exploding
in order to
demonstrate what the advantage is we
have
these two movies at the left hand side
we see simply a solution of
fluorescent molecules
in ep fluorescence
illumination and you see that
that large background
and we can see using epi illumination
normal fluorescence microscopy single
molecules that diffuse around in the
solution
but the contrast is bad and the
background is high
when we use sheet illumination
as seen now on the right hand side we
see that the contrast
incredibly increases and that we really
can make out without any problem single
molecules that diffuse around in that
solution so sheet illumination really
opens a way to produce optical sections
in extended
samples that need to be imaged fastly
if we compare this technique
now something
if we compare this technique with
confocal laser scanning microscopy
for example as shown on the
left hand side
we see that confocal microscopy provides
low frame rates only it has a high photo
damage because we illuminate for each
image the complete sample
we produce a lot of out of focus
fluorescence but that is then finally
removed by the pinhole that is normally
used in confocal microscopy
on the other hand light sheet
fluorescence microscopy can be used with
a very high frame rate because we can
use a parallel data acquisition using
microscopic
high-speed cameras
the imaging method has a very low photo
damage because we only always emit image
those fields and we illuminate only
those fields that we indeed image we
perform no out of focus excitation but
the tense the technique is sensitive to
light absorption
and to scattering light
so
the latter problem can be overcome by
using clearing techniques for example
that is it as it is provided by
expansion microscopy i come to that in a
second
so here we see in the upper sketch
excitation light path of our microscope
actually here we see on the right hand
side a very complex light path which is
used for
airy beam or lattice light sheet
illumination we do that
we do not use that part in the
experiments that i will show
we only use a normal gaussian
illumination
that is then scanned
along the focal plane in order to create
in the time average a light sheet
the sample region illuminated by that
light sheet as shown below is then
imaged by the
an objective lens the focus of that lens
is in the region where we illuminate the
sample
and that image is then
mapped onto a 10 megapixel
scmos scientific camera
we
have the
the option to use several objective
lenses we have a dipping system
and we have one home build system which
is used for very high resolution
experiments and for experiments with a
lower resolution where we need a higher
data throughput with their user blaze
from miltonio biotech
so
so far we we saw how we can acquire
with high speed optical sections from
samples also from ex
extended samples because
with that fast imaging techniques we can
achieve high frame rates
but still we didn't talk about the
problem how to
reach the necessary resolution because
in such samples we have to use usually
low
n a objective lenses and these have a
low optical resolution
so what options exist in order to image
points of interest that are closely
together so that they are
diffracted images overlap as shown here
in that sketch
the well-known one well-known approach
to perform to solve that problem is to
use a point spread function which is
simply sharper than the normal one this
is provided by techniques like
stimulated emission depletion
or
sim or storm
so that is one option but the problem
with these type of techniques is that
they don't reach deep into the sample
due to phase problems
these samples these techniques only
extend about 100 micrometer maximum into
a comp into a extended sample
what you also can do to solve that
problem is not to sharpen the psf
but simply to expand the sample
in that way
you guarantee that the distance between
the points of interest becomes large
enough in order to be resolved
that technique was invented some years
ago
and was introduced by the lab of ed
boyden
here i show you uh in some simple steps
how that expansion techniques in order
to magnify your sample works we see here
a single cell
with some
regions of interest these orange
dots in that image you see a very high
magnification of that on the upper part
of the image
and the steps that we need in order to
produce an expansion of that system is
simply
first by labeling it with fluorescence
in this case for example by
a two-step immunofluorescence labeling
so we achieve
a distribution of the fluorescent labels
on our epitopes
you see that
in the magnification on the right hand
side
the next step is then
to link
the
many chemical residues in this in the in
these proteins with
bifunctional linkers
that then in the next step
can be connected to a gel so
after that linking process we
introduce a polyacryl amid gel actually
in our sample
and the linker connects to the polymers
of this this gel and on the other side
to the proteins
in the next step we go along and
digest
the major part of the proteins not
completely but the major part of the
proteins so that actually the overall
structure of the sample is lost
and we are left with the fluorescent
labels
linked to that gel structure so we don't
have the proteins anymore we have we
have some peptide residues labeled with
the fluorescent dyes and these are
linked by bifunctional linkers to the
gel
already in this step
the sample becomes transparent
usually it expands already by a factor
of about 1.5
but if you now exchange the digestion
buffer pbs is you the the usual buffer
used in this situation
by we distilled water
you find that the sample becomes largely
expanded usually by a factor of four
so that is in some brief words the
technique of expansion microscopy as
introduced by ed boyden
so this approach has
two
key advantages first
we obtain a transparent samples with a
refractive index of water
and secondly actually
uh we we can also do post labeling in
this situation and can in that digested
sample
uh try to achieve additional antibody
labeling
and so digestive sample provides a
better
penetration of such antibodies
so i show you now an example of this
where we applied this expansion
technique to organoids brain organoids
and you can see on the left hand side
the upper image the organwide two months
old and you see that the tiny white dot
in the center
that
is in that that is uh opaque then in the
center image
it is already digested and
transparent and then it expands on the
right hand side in the you see the
magnified gel and then finally we can
image that with a large microscope
so here i show you one example what can
be achieved using this technique in
organoids so we have a sample that is
size several millimeters large and then
we can
zoom into that sample using light sheet
microscopy and we can zoom in so well
that we finally achieve synaptic
resolution
as shown in the lower images
that you finally can also deconvolve
okay this technique now we
applied to thick mouse brain sections
and that will be described by juan and
also the results that we achieved in
this manner
so thanks
um
well
here in this slide you can see
uh
in the upper part like this
sagittal cut
of the mouse brain
that is two millimeters thick and as um
already already explained is a pad so
it's it will be really difficult to
image through the sample
so what we did was we optimized
the technique in order to have like a
completely transparent sample
and then
uh overcoming the problem of the
scattering uh if we want to use lychee
that is like probably the the the most
adequate technique to imagine this kind
of samples
in the in the lower
uh right part you can see like a
sagittal view corresponding to exactly
the same sample where we have in blue
nuclear staining and in green
gfp
and
there is a reason why we are also using
sagittal cuts because there is a more
natural way to follow the
the projections of these neurons from
the hdb to the ob compared to what is
more traditional to use coronal sections
so
now that we know that the sample is is
working properly in this kind of samples
so then
we go
back to the original problem that is
labeling different groups uh
of neurons in the hdb so the hdb is
mostly
made by inhibitory average neurons
modulatory cholinergic neurons and
excitatory glutamatergic neurons
so what we did
and this was done by irena pablo from
from martin's lab so
we took three different mouse groups
that were injected with a virus that
will express gfp in the complete
neuronal cell body and in the
presynaptic uh
part where is a synaptophysin
accumulated we will be expressing
m ruby
so
all right
sensitive then the controls
okay so now you can see the
sagittal view
right of one of these
mouse brain samples
and this is a maximum intensity
projection comprising 200 images
and this was acquired with with the
blaze microscope with a 4x
magnification objective so
you can see in the details of the image
that this image is already about 15
millimeters long
and five millimeters in in
in y direction
if we have the complete volume then we
are able to recognize some important
parts of this circuit
as i'm showing you here in this part
so we can
clearly see the injected neurons in the
hdb
we can also follow the the fiber path
that is going from the hdb to the
olfactory valve and even if this image
is not that clear if we zoom in and we
focus in the olfactory valves then we
are able to see all the fibers that are
connecting there so if you see the scale
of the image you can see that this
circuit is already
here about six millimeters long from the
hdb to the very end of the orbital valve
so that is
a difficult task to achieve with a
different kind of technique
but now if we want to focus and see
where the neurons of the hdb are
projecting into the factory valve
right
so we will focus in the factory valve we
have the complete alpha story valve that
was image with the
with this the blaze of a microscope and
the 4x
uh
but as you saw in the previous image
it's not
that easy to to recognize or to to to
analyze the fibers because they are too
small and we don't have enough
resolution so
as ulrich explained we can
change objective in the in the
microscope and using exactly the same
sample then we can go
with a high magnification objective and
image uh
um
a volume
that contains the comp in the or
photorevolve as you can see there in
yellow
and
if
we take like a
sagittal perspective
we are able to see all the fibers that
are going into the olfactory valves
but also with the same volume and with
the same example we can also get
we can also get the
um
we can make a coronal view
and that is really useful for us because
as you can see there we can recognize
the internal extractor of the olfactory
valve
and we will use that to analyze where
the fibers are projecting
so having that in mind so
in the coronal view you can see that
if we make a line crossing that we can
recognize at least
three of the main
parts of the orbital that is the
glomerular layer the external plexiform
layer and the granule cell layer in the
in the middle and then we have again
external plexiform
and granule cell layer
so
if now
we take in this volume
like a
a projection across
that volume and we measure the
the
mean intensity value
for example in the
with the nuclear staining we have that
that graph
there we can
clearly identify
these three different regions
you have the glomerular layer external
plexiform and the granular layer
and
we can apply that now
to
the intensity but
in the gfp
signal or in the gfp channel
so we can see that
most of the projections in this sample
that is a gabaergic example
so most of the projections are
distributed
like to the center like close to the
granule cell layer
and little in the in the glomerular and
even less in the external plexiform
so with this we analyze
we analyze um
three different mouths of each group so
three mouths of gabaergic cholinergic
and glutamatergic
and we got
different distributions
so for the gabard we can
as i already show you we can see that
most of the projections are concentrated
in the
in the
granule cell layer in the outer part so
probably
the mitral cell layer or something so we
have like 60 more projections in that
area
but if we go to the cholinergic we can
see that
the projections are
more concentrated in the external part
that is the glomerular layer
and finally for the glutamatergic we can
see that projections are mainly like
more than 80 percent of the projections
are just going to the middle part to the
central part of the uh granule cell
layer
so that means that
maybe we can we can uh this give us a
hint that like different neural types
project two different reasons in the
olfactory valve that was what martin was
mentioned in the beginning
and uh
so then we have like a different um
uh
recruitment of the
network individuals there and that's
something that only we can see we look
to the synapses and that's is the next
step
so
here
we have again a sagittal view in the
olfactory valve that was acquired with
the glaze
and if we zoom in
we can see little
dots in magenta in in that magnify
region
but as you can see
the
the
i mean one thing is good is that we can
preserve this this uh
small amount of uh fluorescent proteins
that was
in the synaptism part
but we don't have enough resolution to
identify this presynaptic marker in 3d
okay that was that is important
so
uh then we change then this exactly the
same sample we put it in in our custom
build
uh lighted where we can fit like a
higher magnification objective
and there you can see
that it's
easier or more clear to identify this
this um
pre-synaptic markers
so to be sure we can even go farther and
as i'm i'm showing you here like a
magnification of that region uh but now
with with 100x objective
and we can see that it's actually not an
artifact that that we have like that uh
colocalization in the previous image but
that actually the
the
the pre-synaptic mark is is precisely
located
in this synaptic buttons in the
in the projection
so now
if
we take that
we take a
volume right
with this high magnification objective
uh
in the olfactory valve and i'm showing
you here an exam the example
of the
of the java here
sorry of the
glutamatergic
mouse brain where we have
more like the connections in the center
of the granule cell layer if we take a
volume there with this high
magnification objective
we should be able to see that the number
of synapses so if we count the synapses
along that volume
we should be able to see that
while we are going deep into the sample
the number of synapses should
increase
and that that is what we quantify and
what you can see there in the in the
right part of the um
of the slide
uh so we are able to
identify precisely where the synapses
are
like taking into account the
colocalization of the marker then this m
ruby or the synaptic marker with the gfp
signal
and we did that of course for all the
images
and
and
sorry for all the
the mouse
groups
and we have we found that there is a
main distribution in the granule layer
uh
the cholinergic ones also
project a lot in in to the glomerular
layer but we can see for example the
glutamatergic have almost no
connections in that area
so
finally we can say that the distribution
of different types of neuronal fibers
from the hdb to the ob suggest a
differential and neurotype specific
recruitment
of the network inhibition within the
framework of the olfactory habituation
now
as a summary a more technical summary of
the technique so we can
use
this technique to go from the centimeter
scale to the nanometer scale
using
one sample
so you don't lose information
at all
we optimize this kind of protocol for
like really extended brain slices
we can preserve
even after like really extended uh
digestion cycles all the autofluorescent
proteins
then
with this you are able to do the
analysis of neuronal projections from
the hdb into the photorevel as i already
mentioned also looking into the
distribution or special distribution of
the synapses
so
that's all from from our part i would
like to acknowledge all the people from
from from the biophysical chemistry
group
and of course from the group of the
experimental epileptology and cognition
research
so thanks for for listening so we are
open to questions now
thank you dr schwartz professor kubichek
mr rodriguez for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
how long does the complete preparation
of the mouse brain section take for the
expansion process
so when
a sample like the one that i that i show
uh takes the complete process is about a
week
so
between like sample preparation and the
part that takes longer is actually the
digestion part that was mentioned in
only where we are we have to remove all
the lipids and start to break all the
proteins
to make the sample transparent
see thank you
next question
how long takes uh how long takes a
typical data acquisition session
let's say from the complete volume of
hdb and ob at 4x magnification
um
that usually takes like about one one
day uh with the with the blades and the
four eggs
especially
because we have two different channels
so
and
that's more or less the average
all right thank you
next question
thank you very much for the nice talk so
in expansion microscopy technique
there's no requirement of clearing
solutions
yeah
yeah no um
so
oh yes i mean
so what makes a sample not transparent
is basically the amount of
i mean are the lipids i mean that's the
main source of
things that in the proteins and that's
what we are removing with this digestion
buffer so finally then when you want to
image the sample you can place it either
in pvs to keep it in to expand it 1.5
times or put it in water the advantage
is that you don't need any special kind
of objectives so you can use any any
water immersion objective
or and and you don't need a speci a
special sample chamber for that
so there is no clearing solution
there
all right thank you
next question
how long does it take to image one ob
sample with two different fluorophores
the complete old factory buzz
section uh
with for example with with dappy and gfp
with the 12x is more or less half half a
day
right
next question oh sorry did you have to
add but that that that will depends
always in the type of magnification and
what do you want to see in the sample so
like you can also go like with a really
high magnification and then
it will take longer because then you
have to reduce the step size uh you will
have more tiles that you have to stitch
and so on so
it's it's that's why i'm giving the
example with the 12x just to have um to
give a rough idea of that
all right thank you
next question
how do you optimize the sharpen
algorithm to improve resolution and to
reduce the fake noise signal at the same
time
could you could you
make the question again yes yes um how
do you optimize
the sharpen algorithm to improve
resolution and to reduce the fake noise
signal at the same time
oh um
well maybe maybe that's something that
that i didn't that i forgot to mention
but all the images that i show now they
are
raw images so they don't have any
post-processing
uh
procedure so they are just i mean they
are of course stitched because we take
several tiles but uh the images that i
show
are not uh after the convolution yet so
the idea was to show what you are able
to get just applying the technique and
and getting from the microscope out
great thank you
next question
oh sorry go ahead so maybe one should
add that using the cmos cameras i mean
they are cameras with a very very low no
noise yeah and of course what we always
have
then then finally is a short noise
signal
but this is so low because our labeling
is pretty expensive and pretty optimal
so we
do not really have the problem of
dealing with with a lot of noise
generally
in cases where we have really low
labelings this might happen
and of course then you are limited in
achieving an ultimate resolution because
of the the bad signals this is
but this is a general problem
all right thank you
um next question
do you use anti-fading reagents in your
pbs water when imaging and if yes which
ones
no
no it's
just
pbs with uh sodium aside usually to
avoid any growing thing there but just
pbs
all right thank you
next question
uh
how heavy are the images obtained how to
handle
heavy images
yes that's that's that's true and that's
why is
also recommended or that's why we
we
jump from different objectives depending
what we want to image so
yeah i think that here uh yeah we could
explain yeah we we
we expected such a question so so the
amount of data we deal with in light
sheet microscopy is always really a key
issue
and here
we prepared the table and you can see
that on the right hand side
uh of course depending on the resolution
you are imaging with you
uh produce an amount of data which is
pretty large even from nowadays
computers so with the ultimate
resolution that we that we can obtain
using a 25x objective lens with an na of
1.1
then in order to image a sample of one
millimeter to the power of three
we produce at highest resolution than a
data amount of eight terabytes
and we stream the the data from the
microscope directly on a storage on our
hive and that is directly standing
besides the microscope
and
we stitch this data then together
because of course we have to image these
large extended samples and with a lot of
single tiles that are then fused
together we do that by using fiji
normally so the
the publication by i think stefan
prybish at al
so we use that device and then we import
the the images finally into
image and there we do the processing and
the evaluation of the data so all that
is
an own very special and quite a
demanding task for the computers that
you use
wow thank you
next question
thank you for your informative
presentation how long can the
autofluorescent proteins be preserved
ah this is a very excellent question
because it's of great practical
importance but juan has a good answer to
that
if you keep the sample
uh on pbs at least what we experience is
we can easily
keep a sample
uh in good conditions for up to a year
so if you have to of course change pvs
from time to time but if you keep the
sample in water then it's a problem
because the the
i mean fluorescence like the protein
starts to
uh degradate over time and that
then you can lose the the fluorescence
in one or two weeks
so what we do is usually if we need to
expand the sample we expand it for the
imaging session and after that you can
take the sample you can shrink it again
if you start to wash it with pbs
and then we keep it in pvs for longer
incubation
thank you
no at four degrees yeah you cannot froze
the samples because you have a polymer
gel that is filled with water then if
you put that in minus 20 it will
crystallize and everything is gone
all right
next question
how long
is the preparation suitable for imaging
does it fade out or degrade
uh it's it's i think that that's related
with the with the previous one so if
if you image with the sample in pvs
you don't have any problems so i at
least i have the experience to imagine
the same sample like like really long
just like for testing
but with water is is then you will see
the degradation over time
thank you
next question
would you tell us how the dendritic
spines and their heads and necks are
observed in your experiments
how they
again how they then treated the client
uh would you tell us how the dendritic
spines and their heads and necks
are observed in your experiments
oh i we didn't do any analysis uh on the
then on the spines like like the shape
of the um
yeah
i mean you can see that that slides so
we did that for for
for brain organoids but for mouse brains
we didn't do the
data analysis was was not the focus at
least this time but it's possible to do
because you will have enough resolution
and the 3d information to do that kind
of analysis so if you take a sample like
the one that we are showing in the
lower right part
in emery's
you can use this
tracing tool that is available to to
count and then recognize the spy neck
thank you
so here we have mainly the the
the pre-synaptic marker
so that's what we wanted to to
to show so that's what we we stress here
in this graph
all right
next question
which final optical resolution can be
achieved in your microscope
um
i mean
now if you expand
four times
the sample like like if you put the
sampling water
uh here you can you can see um
what we have is is uh an optical
resolution of 300 nanometers like if you
see the nanoscale like the last
row
with the 25
objective plus the four times expansion
we can achieve like a 300 nanometers
in x and y and axial
one microns that means
that you have to divide that resolution
by four
so we have
about a hundred nanometers resolution in
in in lateral resolution and 300 in
axial resolution
we call that a virtual resolution yeah
because i mean the expanded sample of
course you you have to resize and that i
mean you you don't really improve the
optical resolution this is clear but you
get a virtual resolution in this in your
sample because it is simply larger
and so we really come down to values
that normally are considered to be super
resolution yeah this point one
micrometer this is also so achieved by
structured illumination microscopy
or airy scan confocal microscopy not not
not even actually yeah but
they're close so we are even better than
these techniques and i mean you can also
use these
iterative protocols right so not only
expanded by a factor of four but expand
it by a factor of ten
which
right now which would then allow you to
come down to a lateral resolution of 20
nanometers
great thank you
next question
given the odor specific activation of
hdb fibers within ob
and the fact that the hdb does not
receive input direct input from ob
along which pathway is ob output relayed
into hdb
yeah this is a biological question
it's a good question actually
the hdb does not receive direct input
from the ob and the question is how does
the how does how is this in for this
other information related to the hdb and
we did also
monotron synaptic tracing and found that
the
ob project into the olfactory amygdala
and the effector amygdala project into
the
paraventricular nucleus and from the
paraventricular nucleus then goes the
projection to the hdb which is then
related into the factory bulb
wow
right thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
why do you not image just the complete
sample with high resolution
yeah i mean as as we mentioned and as
you can see in this table
going with a really high resolution to
image the complete sample will be just
like too much data that will not give
you actually more information that the
one that you can
go get if you like kind of partialize
the the your imaging session so i think
that the advantage of this kind of
lighting
systems the one that the one that we
show like the place where you can change
objective
plus the
the fact that you you have like an
entire
um
neuronal circuit containing in in your
sample
is the one that that
actually allows you to get all the
necessary information but in in a let's
say
a smarter way
all right
well thank you dr schwartz professor
kubick mr rodriguez do you have any
closing statements for our audience
yeah
maybe that
since some years we are working on these
techniques and developing our
microscopes in order to optimize that
martin is working on the labeling and
this is uh juan is uh doing the
experiments and the data evaluation so
this is really
a wonderful example for
interdisciplinary science yeah and we
think we are
so successful because we collaborate so
well and and that that works so nicely
all together so in case people are
interested in applying and using these
techniques we are open for contacts and
uh they may just address us and we we
might
need further discussions and we are open
to that absolutely
nothing to add
keep up the spirit of sydney brenna
right
well thank you again dr schwartz
professor cubacek mr rodriguez for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye
you